T
IS 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
REPUBLICANS DEMANDING SOME
ANSWERS AFTER CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS WERE FOUND AT
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S FORMER OFFICE
JUST DAYS BEFORE THE MIDTERMS,
THE MATERIALS ARE FROM HIS TIME
AS VICE PRESIDENT, AND A NEW
REPORT SAYS THAT THEY INCLUDE
INTELLIGENCE ASSESSMENTS ABOUT
UKRAINE, IRAN, AND THE U.K.
THE WHITE HOUSE CLAIMS THE
DOCUMENTS WERE IMMEDIATELY
HANDED OVER TO THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES AND THE JOE BIDEN
ATTORNEYS ARE WORKING WITH THE
DOJ, THE PRESIDENT DOES NOT SEEM
TO TALK ABOUT ANY OF IT.
>> AND WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK --
>> TOP G.O.P. LAWMAKERS CLAIM
THERE IS A DOUBLE STANDARD AT
PLAY AFTER THE FBI RAID ON
MAR-A-LAGO.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID DURING
THE CAMPAIGN HE WOULD BE THE
MOST TRANSPARENT WITH
FRUSTRATION IN AMERICA, YET WE
FIND OUT THIS HAPPENED
NOVEMBER THE 2ND, DAYS BEFORE
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS AND NO ONE
FOUND OUT ABOUT IT.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE QUICK TO
JUDGE, I JUST KNOW THAT HE SAID
IT WAS VERY IRRESPONSIBLE FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO TAKE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS INTO HIS
PERSONAL RESIDENCE AND HAVE THEM
IN AN UNSECURE LOCATION AND IT
APPEARS HE DID THE SAME THING.
>> Dana: AND SOME OF THE MEDIA
QUICK TO DISMISS THE STORY.
TO SPEAK OF THE EUPHORIA ON THE
RIGHT THAT THIS WOULD SOMEHOW
EXONERATE DONALD TRUMP IS
ALREADY TURNED INTO A BIT OF A
HANGOVER BECAUSE OF THE STARK
CONTRAST BETWEEN THE ACTIONS OF
THE CURRENT PRESIDENT AND A
FORMER GUY WHEN IT COMES TO
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL.
>> WE ALL KNOW THAT DONALD TRUMP
IS A LIAR AND A THIEF, WE DON'T
THINK THAT JOE BIDEN IS A LIAR
AND A THIEF COULD SO WE GIVE HIM
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
>> YOU ARE EQUATING IT TO WHAT
HAPPENED WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP EVEN THOUGH IT
IS APPLES TO ORANGES SITUATION.
>> Dana: YOU BROKE THE NEWS TO
ME IN A COMMERCIAL BREAK
YESTERDAY AND I LOOKED AT IN AND
HAD TERRIBLE THOUGHTS, FIRST I
THOUGHT IT WAS A JOKE, LIKE
BABYLON BEE, AND THE SECOND
THING I THOUGHT IT WAS IF YOU
ARE IN THE COMMUNICATIONS OFFICE
AND THEY HAVE TO CALL YOU AND
TELL YOU THIS, YOU IMMEDIATELY
WANT TO THROW UP YOUR HANDS AND
GO I DON'T KNOW WHAT I CAN DO
WITH YOU HERE.
>> HOW DARE RACHEL MADDOW SNEER
AT EXONERATION.
THAT IS THE CORNERSTONE OF WHAT
I DO HERE, AND I WILL BE DOING
IT VERY EFFECTIVELY.
I JUST WANT TO TAKE THAT SLOWLY,
SO INTELLIGENCE REPORTS DEALING
WITH UKRAINE, BRITAIN, AND IRAN,
AND THESE WERE TAKEN OUT RIGHTS
WHEN HE WAS LEAVING THE VICE
PRESIDENCY, SO UKRAINE WHAT HE
IS TRYING TO HIDE FROM THE
UPCOMING TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
OBVIOUSLY, THE BRITISH
INTELLIGENCE IS INTERESTING,
BECAUSE THIS WAS A
CHRISTOPHER STEELE DEAL WITH THE
RUSSIA COLLUSION AND IRAN, WHAT
WAS HE GOING TO DO?
NUKE THE NUKE DEAL, SO WE DID
NOT WANT TO TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
TO HAVE HIS DIRTY LITTLE HANDS
ON ANY OF THOSE THINGS, SO HE
DISAPPEARS WITH THE DOCUMENTS.
AND THE JOE BIDEN CENTER FOR
DIPLOMACY, THEY CALL IT A
THINK TANK WHICH IS --
>> Dana: GENEROUS.
>> GENEROUS, THEY DON'T OPEN FOR
A YEAR, SO WHERE ARE THE
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE CLASSIFIED
FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR, AND THEN WHO
MOVES THOSE DOCUMENTS INTO THE
THINK TANK IF YOU CAN CALL IT
THAT?
NOW ALSO AT THE LAST WEEK OF THE
JOE BIDEN VICE PRESIDENCY, WHERE
WAS BIDEN?
HE WAS IN UKRAINE, HE WENT ALL
THE WAY OVER TO UKRAINE FOR SOME
REASON AND THAT PROSECUTOR WAS
FIRED AND BURIES HIM A GIVES A
LOAD OF MONEY INTO THE ATLANTIC
COUNCIL, EVERYTHING WRAPS UP IN
A NICE BOW, SO THEN THEY OPEN
THE JOE BIDEN CENTER WITH
CHINESE MONEY, HE ANNOUNCES HE
IS DOING THE BUYING AND CENTER A
NEW PEN AND ALL OF US ON IN
CHINA QUADRUPLES THEIR NATIONS
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA, A LOT OF IT
ANONYMOUS, SO THEY OPEN UP THIS
BIG CENTER, 65, $75 MILLION,
DONATIONS FLOODING IN AND THE
BIDEN CENTER AND YOU PENNED
SPECIFICALLY HAVE ALL OF THE
INSTITUTIONS IN THE IVY LEAGUE
THE MOST PRO-CHINA, THE BIGGEST
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CHINESE,
AND THEIR MANTRA IS BASICALLY
LIKE, WE CAN'T DECOUPLE FROM
CHINA, CHINA IS GREAT, AND THE
BIDEN CENTER IS AT THE FOREFRONT
OF THIS BIG EFFORT, IN TERMS OF
NATIONAL SECURITY IMPLICATIONS,
WHERE DO YOU THINK THE CHINESE
HAVE GREATER ACCESS?
TO A THINK TANK 15 MINUTE BIKE
RIDE FROM THE CHINESE EMBASSY IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., OR A BASEMENT
ADD TO MAR-A-LAGO ON AN ISLAND
IN FLORIDA GUARDED BY THE
SECRET SERVICE?
I WONDER IF THE JANITORS AT THE
BIDEN CENTER WERE CHINESE
OPERATIVES?
I CAN ONLY GUESS, BUT I FEEL
LIKE IT'S JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
SUSPICIOUS.
AND THERE ARE OTHER EMAILS
COMING OUT FROM THE HUNTER
LAPTOP LOOKING AT THE BIDEN
CENTER AS THE CLINTON GLOBAL
INITIATIVE, AND I THINK THAT
HUNTER BIDEN WAS GOING TO HAVE
AN OFFICE, WHY DOES HE NEED AN
OFFICE AT THE CENTER WHEN HE
ALREADY HAS THIS OTHER OFFICE
THAT HE IS SHARED WITH THE
CHINESE IN GEORGETOWN?
A LOT OF CENTERS, AND YOU CAN
NEVER GET ANYTHING OUT OF THE
CENTER'S COMING YOU KNOW THEY
HAD TO CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AT
THIS ONE, AND THEN THEY HAVE ALL
OF THE DOCUMENTS ABOUT THE RAPE
ACCUSATION FROM THAT WOMAN WHEN
HE WAS A SENATOR AND HAVE THOSE
LOCKED ON REGARDING KEY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF DELAWARE, IT'S
LIKE EVERY INSTITUTION BIDEN IS
ASSOCIATED WITH HAS SOME SORT OF
NATIONAL SECURITY OR CRIMINAL
IMPLICATION, SO I'M JUST, I AM
KEEPING AN OPEN MIND AS HAROLD
WOULD SAY.
>> Dana: YES, AND WHAT ABOUT
THAT WHAT ABOUTISM.
>> Harold: IT'S GREAT TO BE
BACK.
I WOULD SAY THAT JESSE HAS
RAISED A LOT OF POINTS, AND A
LOT OF QUESTIONS NEED TO BE
ANSWERED, I DON'T THINK THAT
PENN IS THE MOST EXPENSES, BUT
HARVARD MAY HAVE THE MOST
STUDENTS FROM CHINA, BUT IT ALL
MITIGATES ANSWERS THAT I THINK
NEED TO BE ASKED AND QUESTIONS
THAT DESERVE ANSWERS, I WOULD
SAY FOUR OTHER THINGS VERY
QUICKLY, WHAT I AM MOST
INTERESTED IN IN ALL OF THIS IS
HOW DID IT HAPPEN?
I THINK WE NEED TO CHASE THE
TRAIN OF CUSTODY, AND FROM A
LEGAL STANDPOINT, JUDGE, THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE DONE
TOO, DID PRESIDENT BIDEN AND ONE
OF HIS CITIZEN BIDEN'S BEFORE HE
WAS PRESIDENT EVER REVIEW THOSE
DOCUMENTS?
I THINK IF HE DID HE WOULD HAVE
KNOWN THAT THEY WERE THERE AND
THAT THEY SHOULD'VE BEEN
RETURNED, AND IF HE DID REVIEW
THEM, DID HE KNOW THAT THEY WERE
CLASSIFIED AND SOMEBODY TELL
THEM THAT THEY SHOULD BE
RETURNED?
IF HE REVIEWED THEM, HE SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN, BECAUSE THEY WERE
LISTED THAT WAY.
THREE, HOW SECURE THE DOCUMENTS?
SOME OF THE CONCERNS PEOPLE HAD
ABOUT THE DOCUMENTS BEING AT
MAR-A-LAGO WAS THAT AT LEAST
FROM WHAT WE HEARD IN THE
ARCHIVE IN FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IS THAT
THE FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY AND FBI IS THAT THEY DID
NOTHING THOSE THINGS WERE SECURE
ENOUGH, AND FINALLY, HAD THEY
CHECKED EXHAUSTIVELY TO MAKE
SURE THERE WERE NO OTHER
DOCUMENTS?
ONE DISTINGUISHING FACT IS THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S TEAM
APPARENTLY SELF-REPORTED, AND IF
THEY SELF REPORTED ON THIS, I'VE
READ SOME REPORTS WHERE THEY
LOOKED IN OTHER BOXES AND I AM
HOPEFUL THAT THEY DID LOOK IN
OTHER BOXES THAT THEY HAVE
EXHAUSTIVELY DONE THE SEARCH,
BUT POLITICALLY YOU ARE RIGHT,
YOU WOULD HATE TO GET THAT CALL
YESTERDAY.
THESE THINGS HAPPEN, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING THE
PRESIDENT'S ANSWERS TO THESE
QUESTIONS.
>> Dana: WE WILL SEE IF HE
GETS ONE, THERE WILL BE A PRESS
CONFERENCE AND A LITTLE BIT,
WHAT ABOUT THE ACTION?
HE SAID SOMEBODY WILL HAVE TO
LOOK INTO THIS AS WELL.
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T TRUST THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ENOUGH TO SAY
THAT HE IS PROBABLY GOING TO
RECOMMEND A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR,
HE IS NOT GOING TO DO THAT, I
THINK THAT THE POINTS THAT
HAROLD RAISED ARE EXCELLENT,
NUMBER ONE, THE ATTORNEY
STUMBLED UPON THE USE TOP SECRET
STUFF THAT YOU COULD ONLY READ
IN THE SKIFF THAT ARE MARKED
CLASSIFIED, OKAY, NUMBER TWO,
THEY HAVE BEEN THERE FOR SIX
YEARS IN A FACILITY THAT IS NOT
LOCKED, THAT IS NOT SECURED, WE
HAVE NO IDEA HOW MANY PEOPLE HAD
ACCESS TO OR ACTUALLY LOOKED AT
THESE DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
MARKED, AND THERE WAS -- IT WAS
NOT ONLY NOT SECURE, BUT IT
WASN'T AN ACADEMIC INSTITUTION,
ANYBODY COULD'VE HAD ACCESS TO
THAT OFFICE, AND MY QUESTION IS,
WHY NOW?
WHERE THEY MOVE IN THE OFFICE?
I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY WERE
MOVING THE OFFICE AND THEN THEY
SAID THAT THEY TURNED IT OVER
IMMEDIATELY, IMMEDIATELY AFTER
WHAT?
AFTER WHO SAW IT?
WHO SAW IT FIRST?
WHAT WAS THE MEDIAN?
AND HOW MANY PEOPLE SAW IT?
I WANT TO KNOW UNDER OATH HOW
MANY PEOPLE SAW IT?
WHAT OTHER CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION IS THERE?
I WON'T RELY ON THEM SAYING THIS
IS THIS AMOUNT, THE SMALL AMOUNT
IS NOT THE ISSUE, THE ISSUE IS
VERY CLEAR, YOU DO NOT HAVE THE
RIGHT TO TAKE THAT CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND PUT IT IN THE
NONCLASSIFIED FACILITY, OKAY?
THAT IS A VIOLATION WHETHER IT
IS ONE OR 160, RIGHT NOW THEY
ARE OMITTING TO TEN OR 12 OR
WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS, SO IT IS
NOT ALLOWED.
MATT SO DON'T TELL ME, THE
MEDIA, LIKE THE MEDIA THERE IS
NOTHING TO SEE HERE, FOLKS,
NOTHING TO SEE HERE, AT LEAST
MAR-A-LAGO WAS PROTECTED BY THE
SECRET SERVICE.
THIS IS AN ACADEMIC INSTITUTION,
AND THE TRUTH IS UKRAINE, YOU
KNOW, AS I RECALL,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS IMPEACHED
OVER A PHONE CALL TO THE UKRAINE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
JOE BIDEN DID WHEN HE THREATENED
TO PROSECUTE OFF THE CASE OF A
COMPANY THAT HIS SON WAS WORKING
FOR.
AND BY THE WAY, HIS
VICE PRESIDENT, HE DID NOT HAVE
POWER TO DECLASSIFY, SO KNOCKING
OFF THOSE DEFENSES, AND THE MAN
WHO CANNOT WAIT CALL
DONALD TRUMP IRRESPONSIBLE NOW
CAN'T ANSWER THE QUESTION.
HE CAN'T ANSWER ANY QUESTION,
AND FINALLY THE WHAT ABOUTISM, I
WOULD LIKE TO DO WHAT ABOUTISM
WITH HILLARY CLINTON, SHE STILL
IS THE WORST.
33,000 EMAILS AND THEY WERE ALL
CLASSIFIED, WHICH EVERYBODY
ASKED WHERE THEY WORK?
SHE SIMPLY DESTROYED THEM.
>> Dana: WHY ISN'T THE MEDIA
MAD ABOUT THE TIMING?
BECAUSE APPARENTLY THIS WAS
KNOWN BEFORE THE MIDDLE
ELECTIONS?
>> WHAT A SURPRISE THAT IT CAME
OUT NOW, ALL OF THESE DELAYS
SEEM TO ONLY GO IN ONE
DIRECTION, WHERE THE SHOCKING
PHOTOGRAPHS THAT ARE SET UP LIKE
COURT EVIDENCE?
I SAID THIS A COUPLE OF DAYS
AGO, PAYBACK IS A
HILLARY CLINTON.
AND I WANT TO KNOW WHEN THE RAID
STARTS, I WENT TO SEE WHAT IS IN
THEIR UNDERWEAR DRAWER, AND IF
IT IS DISPOSABLE, I KNOW THAT
THE MEDIA'S RESPONSE IS THAT
WITH DONALD TRUMP IT IS TREASON
OR WORSE THAN WATERGATE AND WHAT
JOE BIDEN IT IS A NOTHING
SUPPOSITORY, WE SEE THAT COMING
AS WELL AND KNEW THAT THIS WOULD
HAPPEN, WE ARE NOT STUPID, BUT
WE ARE DIFFERENT, RIGHT?
THEY MAY BE RIGHT, THIS MIGHT BE
A NOTHING-BURGER, AND WE FELT
THAT DONALD TRUMP'S WAS A
NOTHING-BURGER, BUT WE NEVER
CHANGE OUR STORY BASED ON THE
TEAM THAT WE SUPPORT.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS PROBABLY,
IN MY VIEW I WOULD ALWAYS THINK
THAT THE PERSON WHO PACKED THAT
STUFF IN THERE PROBABLY JUST
PACK STUFF IN THERE.
IF YOU HAVE OR HAVE A MOVER THAT
COMES TO YOUR HOUSE AND THEN YOU
ARE UNPACKING AND THEY PACKED
SINGULARLY OUT DISPOSABLE SWOON
FROM TAKE OUT?
AND IT'S ALL PACKED A NEWSPAPER?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
SO WHO KNOWS, IT COULD BE SOME
IDIOT, BUT THE THING IS I WOULD
NOT BE DOING MY JOB IF I DID NOT
RAISE THE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
THAT NEED TO BE RAISED ABOUT
WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
DO WE KNOW THAT THERE AREN'T
NUCLEAR SECRETS IN THERE?
PERHAPS HE EXCHANGE NUCLEAR
SECRETS TO CHINA FOR THE 10%,
THAT'S A QUESTION WORTH RAISING.
WHAT IF HE HAS BARACK OBAMA'S
REAL BIRTH CERTIFICATE, AND
THAT'S WHAT GOT HIM THE VP JOB!
HE IS THE BLACK MALE, THE BLACK
MALE.
BUT IF THIS IS TRUE, AND BY THE
WAY, JUST RAISING QUESTIONS,
DOCUMENTS FILING THE NATIONAL
SECURITY, HE NEEDS TO BE FROG
MARCHED TO JOE BIDEN INTO PRISON
IMMEDIATELY, NO BAIL FOR HIM,
AND IF IT TURNS OUT HE IS A
TRAITOR, I'M JUST GOING TO GO BY
WITH ALL OF THOSE TALKING HEADS
ON CNN AND